she had a huge heart she was a very
compassionate campaign ENT she was a
bright star no doubt about it into star
for her constituents a star in
parliament and a star right across the
house and we've lost a star a beacon of
hope who believed in love friendship and
values that we all so much need at this
time Jolie was her voice for those who
have none she dedicated her passion to
devote to those who needed it most and
she harnessed her limitless love even
and especially for those who will out
hate to consume them when he thought Joe
in the morning if you knew you were
gonna have a good day because she's just
radiated optimism and hope and warm she
lived for this community she served this
community and in the end she gave her
life for this community we've lost a
wonderful woman we've lost a wonderful
member of parliament but our democracy
will go on her work will go on as we
mourn her memory will work in her memory
to achieve that better world she spent
her life trying to achieve